dr anderson montgomery a researcher for
the scp foundation was 35 years old when
he received the call he knew would
change his life forever he was one of
those guys you could best described as
married to the job he'd never shown any
interest in outside hobbies as far as
anyone at the foundation knew he never
developed a love life or had any real
enthusiasm towards the idea of one he
devoted all his time and energy to work
grinding away putting in the hours and
doing whatever his employers asked of
him and now he was going to be punished
for it the call came from a senior site
19 researcher dr gregory van divier an
old stern foundation veteran he'd worked
under on a few projects in the past dr
van divier with his trademark calm
authoritative voice said you've been
selected for scp-231 duty you'll be
working directly under my supervision
pending the results of the mandated
psychological evaluations you'll be
assisting me and the rest of the scp-231
team in carrying out procedure 110
montauk i look forward to working with
you the feeling was not mutual when the
call ended the normally stoic and
professional dr montgomery was in a cold
sweat he'd heard legends about scp-231
and of procedure 110 montauk the
foundation has needed to do some extreme
things to keep dangerous anomalies
contained from sacrificing people to
scp-2845 the deer and
scp-974 the tree house predator to
murdering any civilian who gets too
close to scp-823
the carnival of horrors but procedure
110 montauk is a different league it is
a containment measure so horrifying that
for many at the foundation it is
literally unspeakable the knowledge of
his impending transfer drove dr
montgomery to do something he'd never
done before
socialize he asked around to some of his
fellow site 19 researchers querying as
to whether any of them had performed or
knew anyone who had performed procedure
110 montauk on
scp-231 he was met with many blank
haunted faces and stairs that seemed to
look right through him they told him
that nobody in the history of the
foundation had ever taken on montauk
detail and not accepted a course of
feministic therapy afterward nobody
who'd done it wanted to remember their
part in the atrocity and perhaps that
was the only consolation once you've
done it at least they'll give you the
choice to forget as dr van divier had
alluded to over the phone the battery of
tests performed to prepare dr montgomery
for his new duty was extensive he was
given the milgram obedience examination
which involved being ordered to
knowingly give an innocent man
electrical shocks you have to score at
least 72 on the test to qualify for
scp-231 detail thorough background
checks were conducted into every facet
of his life no stone was unturned in
making sure that dr montgomery would be
the right man for the job and nobody was
less certain about the answer to that
than dr anderson montgomery himself he
knew about scp-231
everyone at the foundation did after all
if there was a 100 megaton nuclear bomb
sitting in your bedroom closet wouldn't
you at least want to know that it was
there that's what
scp-231 was all about except that it
makes a nuclear weapon look like a
gentle kiss good night in comparison if
ever scp-231 is compromised it means the
end of reality as we know it and the
beginning of a true nightmare it all
started with a warehouse a long time ago
a warehouse purchased and registered
under the name d spivak believed to be
the infamous person of interest depeche
spivak a power player in a little cult
known as the children of the scarlet
king as the name suggests they worship
the eponymous scarlet king one of the
most powerful and dangerous beings in
the entire multiverse
a nightmare god who represents chaos
cruelty and primal violence the scarlet
king's followers were constantly
planning and executing new attempts to
allow their master into our reality and
the latest one was centered around this
humble little warehouse on the edge of a
city perhaps not too far from yours
noise complaints had caused suspicion to
fall upon this warehouse screaming and
chanting in the dead of night loud
footsteps
scraping metal when the police arrived
to check in on the noise complaint they
were met with startling force robe
strangers with heavy weaponry gun them
down left and right what on earth were
these maniacs defending in there a drug
lab arms dealing human trafficking the
true answer would be even worse luckily
for the first responders they had an
unexpected calvary swoop in to save the
day a well-armed and well-trained scp
foundation mobile task force they
repelled the cultists and soon took over
the investigation only to find that the
terrible secret inside the warehouse was
going to be a handful even for them
seven girls chained up and neglected
each one the victim of horrible rituals
and deeds by the cultists appeared to be
at late stages of pregnancy the
foundation escorted the seven girls away
to a secure containment chamber
apprehending a few of their captors
alive and also managed to collect a
series of notebooks detailing the
disgusting nature of the rituals it was
a perfect example of how sometimes mere
humans can be the greatest monsters of
all speaking of monsters something awful
happened the night that the seven girls
designated scp-231-1-7
were brought in during the recovery
operation
scp-231-1 began having violent
contractions and then suddenly gave
birth the incredibly aggressive anomaly
she gave birth to that night killed not
only her but over a hundred others the
doctors and researchers who were unlucky
enough to be in the area and many of the
trained foundation soldiers that were
sent in to stop it it became quickly
apparent that this situation was out of
control and each one of the remaining
six girls might give birth to an even
more powerful threat
senior researcher dr robert montauk was
brought in to take over the scp-231 case
the debate would go on among foundation
staff for years as to whether he was the
best or worst person for that particular
job you see dr montauk had a storied
history with the children of the scarlet
king the cult that had created scp-231
many years before his younger brother
jacob had gone missing never to be seen
again and he believed that they were the
ones behind the disappearance naturally
dr montauk thought a little revenge was
in order many at the foundation believe
that this rage this desire to get back
at the cultists and the scarlet king
caused him to create a procedure as
horrifying as the one that would forever
bear his name he conceived it after
obsessively reading through the cult's
notebooks and conducting brutal
interrogations against the members of
the cult that they had captured he had
even taken the cult's own inhuman
methods and reverse engineered them
making them even more barbaric in the
process it was an act so devoid of
compassion and decency that many believe
dr montauk would later go insane and
become an enemy of the very foundation
that allowed him to exact his revenge
since then
scp-231 has become an anomaly marred by
tragedy after tragedy foundation
scientists attempted to terminate the
pregnancy of scp-231-2
but instead this simply induced her to
give birth it was another huge disaster
with scores of people as cp 231-2
included being killed in the process
scp-231-3 is believed to have died due
to the sheer intensity of the procedure
110 montauk protocols and once again
released an entity in the process that
went on to cause a massive loss of life
scp-231-4 was given a sample of scp-500
the panacea which is a collection of
pills that can cure anything it did
cause her to successfully eject the 231
fetus but this fetus then went on to
cause another mass casualty event
killing
scp-231-4 and so many others a botched
application of the montauk procedure was
what set off scp-231-5
and resulted in not only a huge number
of additional deaths but the destruction
of site 231-elf
the entire site used in the holding of
scp-231 specimens the montauk procedure
also caused the incident with scp-231-a
though in a slightly more indirect way a
rogue agent had been driven mad with
guilt by his part in procedure 110
montauk and tried to escape with
scp-231-6
the resulting firefight caused
scp-231-6 to give birth killing her the
rogue agent and everyone else unlucky
enough to be caught nearby
every time one of these incidents
occurred the disaster got worse by all
current foundation projections if ever
scp-231-7 gave birth it'd be a coin toss
on whether it caused an xk-class
end-of-the-world scenario and that's not
the kind of risk the scp foundation can
ever leave to chance performing
procedure 110 montauk at least once
every 24 hours on
scp-231-7 was the only way to ensure
humanity's continued safety from the
scarlet king the d-class is forced to
perform the procedure first hand are
even given explosive collars so the
foundation can literally blow their head
off if they show a moment's hesitation
all these thoughts and so many others
were swimming through dr anderson
montgomery's mind when he was finally
escorted to the secure and secretive
facility where
scp-231-7 is kept and procedure 110
montauk is carried out it's so
classified that dr montgomery needed to
be blindfolded and switched between
seven different vehicles during the
journey he was told that if he ever
attempted to remove the blindfold in
transit he would be immediately shot no
questions asked when he arrived he found
himself staring into the stony face of
dr gregory van divier a weathered man
who had seen things he wished he could
forget when young dr montgomery walked
with him they walked in relative silence
except for when dr van divier needed to
deliver an order you just didn't talk
about the kind of thing they were about
to take part in though dr montgomery
could feel it looming over him like a
shadow they passed through more security
checkpoints on the way to the control
room as dr montgomery's palms began to
sweat he wished with everything in him
that he could turn back that he could
run for his life but there was no time
if he did that now he'd probably catch a
bullet in the back but would even that
be better than this the two doctors soon
arrived in the control room monitors
everywhere showing an empty room with a
single bed curiously montgomery noticed
that a d-class was fluffing a pillow on
the bed that's when the countdown began
procedure 110 montauk was about to
commence the sheer anticipation had dr
montgomery on the edge of vomiting and
when the doors opened and a heavily
pregnant scp-231-7
entered the chamber he almost fainted
the girl laid out on the bed moments
later a lone d-class entered the room he
was carrying a book he took a seat on a
chair near
scp-231-7's bed and said hello again
catherine i brought you a new one
tonight it's called good night moon is
that okay he then to the immense
surprise of dr montgomery read
scp-231-7 a bedtime story until she
drifted off to sleep and with that
procedure 110 montauk was over dr
montgomery didn't understand had he gone
insane did his mind invent all of this
just to be more comfortable with what he
was actually seeing but before he could
ponder anymore dr van divier placed a
fatherly hand on dr montgomery's
shoulder and finally gave him his
explanation the piece of the puzzle that
made everything come together you see
procedure 110 montauk has never been a
monstrous method of torture it's never
been a horrific atrocity but for it to
work everyone needed to believe it was
after all the scarlet king doesn't watch
over everything like some biblical god
he only feels and what he feels
strongest of all is terror hate and
revulsion no harm ever needed to befall
catherine the girl known as scp-231-7
because the worst thing imaginable had
already happened to her the foundation
instead did something far more clever
through lying to even their own ranks
they lied to the scarlet king too it was
fear alone that sold the lie enough fear
to mask the scent of their hidden
compassion and it was a lie that the
scarlet king himself along with the rest
of us bought hook line and sinker after
all evil doesn't beat evil good does now
go check out
scp-001 the scarlet king and children of
scp-001 the scarlet king is
scp-999 really his son for more on the
scarlet king and the way his horrific
deeds affect our world